we are going to talk about tonight's
vice presidential debate but first we
need to finish talking about last week's
presidential debate the big question
about the first presidential debate last
week was not so much who won the debate
which is a more amorphous question but
the measurable question of how did that
debate affect polling a ton of
right-wingers have been tweeting me
links to these bogus insta online polls
like the drudge report dot com poll some
of them showing that Donald Trump one
really big one of them said Trump won
8220 listen not only are those internet
polls obviously not scientific in any
way the results don't even pass the
laugh test based on just an
understanding of how polarized politics
is in the United States right now nobody
won that debate 8020 in any serious
manner so we've been waiting for polling
numbers from actual pollsters and now we
have them okay in four way polling which
includes libertarian Gary Johnson and
Green Party presidential candidate Jill
Stein Hillary Clinton is defeating
Donald Trump in listen to this nine out
of nine post-debate polls these are
polls done we're all surveying of voters
happened after that first debate let's
take a look at a screenshot from Real
Clear Politics dot-com as you can see
here dating back to a rasmussen results
poll from uh starting the day of the
debate which had Hillary Clinton plus
one you will see that Hillary Clinton is
leading every single one of these polls
by a margin of somewhere between one and
six percentage points an average
according to Real Clear Politics of 3.7
percentage points very solid numbers for
Hillary Clinton but you don't win or
lose the presidential election in the
United States based on national
electoral I'm sorry national popular
vote because we have an electoral vote
system you need 270 electoral votes to
become president of the United States so
next let's look at the updated election
forecast from nate silver's
fivethirtyeight.com as of this morning
you will see he estimates Hillary
Clinton has roughly a seventy two
percent chance of becoming the next
president of the United States Donald
Trump has a roughly twenty eight percent
chance of becoming president of the
United States Gary Johnson has somewhere
between a below uh below zero point one
and one percent chance of becoming
president of the United States now the
interesting thing if we can put that one
back up just for a second if you look I
don't know must be uh ten days ago
basically if you look at this right
before that first presidential debate
you see that Hillary Clinton's chance of
winning trailed off trailed off from
mid-august in a very uh acute and steep
fashion until that first presidential
debate at which point Hillary Clinton's
chance of winning the national election
has increased according to
fivethirtyeight.com and lastly I want to
show you the state-by-state polling map
from electoral dash vote dot-com this
takes state by state polls and tells us
what do these add up to in terms of
electoral votes interestingly here
Hillary Clinton ahead in Florida but
Donald Trump ahead in Ohio an important
state 323 to 215 is the current estimate
from electoral dash vote dot-com look at
North Carolina in that nap north
carolina uh in the blue camp for Hillary
Clinton right now unclear if that will
stay if it does I think we will likely
have Gary Johnson to thank they're
currently Hillary Clinton leads Trump by
about 2 percentage points in North
Carolina Gary Johnson is polling 7%
there and there is no doubt that if Gary
Johnson were not running the lion's
share of his seven percent would not go
to Hillary Clinton it would go to Donald
Trump so if Hillary Clinton ends up
winning north carolina on november
eighth we may have gary johnson to thank
it would be great to have gary johnson
to thank for something because right now
i guess we can thank him for two
cringe-worthy moments where he exposed
he he uh either has significant memory
problems
doesn't know a lot of stuff will
tonight's vice presidential debate
change these numbers I say it's very
unlikely typically unless someone to
something really outrageously bad in a
vice presidential debate you are not
going to see any big impact although
though the one thing that crossed my
mind is Donald Trump is so incompetent
and clueless on every issue that in
comparison Mike Pence is going to seem
like uh a knowledgeable guy now his
positions are bonkers off-the-wall
insane but compared to trump he may
actually seem to know something and that
pat might I guess make it so some
undecided voters I don't know how you
can be undecided right now say hey you
know what I was worried about Trump cuz
he doesn't know anything but pence seems
to at least be aware of some stuff so
maybe I'll vote for him because I really
don't like Hillary I don't know I'm REE
I'm reaching pretty deep here yeah you
are i think if uh the pressures on
anyone it is on Mike Pence because yes
to overcome Trump's first debate
performance which was reviewed by pretty
much everyone as lackluster yeah except
for people who voted on drudge report
dot com uh de to the extent that that
matters I honestly don't understand
being undecided at this point it's a
month before the race how can you still
be undecided and sometimes undecideds
where they're undecidedness like a badge
of honor suggesting or implying that
they're somehow better but they're
really taking their time to evaluate who
to vote for how can you possibly be
undecided at this point I truly don't
get that